I saw your videos and man you changed my
life thank you so much for everything
it's been a tough year got a lot of love
for you I love you so much man I love
you back taking a lot of Courage so I
can quit my job last year I was able to
live my dream and I listened to your
podcast all the time and you gave me
courage to get out there today I'm proud
of you bro
let this be very [__] clear love is
unfucking defeated
[Music]
I did trade attention and build
businesses
Legacy is greater than currency
like documented I'm glad you're here for
defense Canada it's great to see you oh
my gosh great to have you too hi Hi how
are you
I'm so grateful for each and every one
of you this is the guy that brought us
here and we are so grateful for you man
thank you thank you
last year V con completely changed my
life bro you have no no idea I do you
know that's what I was saying to
everybody like it's like-minded people
it's the same [__] it's tribalism if
humans are wired to be in tribes the
problem is see the last decade has been
built on more negativity tri-based which
is why this tribe matters so much to me
of course you got a pen I don't here's
everything but the Sharpie
[Music]
thank you
my favorite tweet I've ever made some
kids got a photo the airport he goes
about to hop on my plane missing class
to go to Beacon means I'm doing five
hours of homework on the plane see you
soon I quote retweet it homework life
this means he will do five more hours of
homework on this plane than I did in my
entire High School career combined no
way my life been looking gorgeous
got bad women for me today man he need
to force it I'm standing with the torch
cooked in my hand I'm heliconing the
other Palm hold my fortune I know how
exciting it is
a community come to life what would be
your advice especially for anybody out
there who's trying to get their side
hustle with their business and maybe
they're not the best at connecting with
people I believe the only way to get
better at something is to practice and
fail and I think one of the biggest
issues in our society is that we've
demonized losing for kids the reason I'm
so overly passionate on eighth place
trophies is because I know it's hurting
people when you teach a child that
losing's bad so much so that we're going
to give everyone who lost a trophy too
because we can't have you feeling bad
well then they get scared of it I was
mad when people took their second and
third place trophies I was like leave
that [__] we lost what do I think people
should do I think they should say hello
to people but they're scared because if
that person shuns them their feelings
are hurt as if that person's value is
any greater than theirs because if you
do it two out of nine are going to be
super lovely and that's your connection
that you're looking for but people are
literally scared of rejection because of
insecurity and insecurity starts early
life's about losing with an occasional
win thank you Gary thank you everybody
so thank you everyone have a great
weekend really have a great weekend
good how you feeling about your your
sessions excited to moderate I was like
you know this is a safe space I can
curse I'm so [__] excited good I get
asked a lot because I consult with a lot
of entrepreneurs and women I think the
thing that they're people are always
trying to get out of me is like what's
the magic sauce and there isn't correct
if you can point to a couple things that
have brought you to here today to this
level of successful can you name a
couple things yes but I'm going to
actually take a stab at the impossible
question I absolutely believe that the
women that listen to this are going to
really resonate with what I'm about to
say the magic formula for most currently
today to stop judging themselves so much
really really women have an incredible
DNA structure when they have children to
having to balance the two most important
things in the world themselves and their
Ambitions and this subconscious
conscious responsibility to be a mother
and they're beating themselves up 24 7.
you can't do two things at once give
yourself a break therapy about to make
me cry I would tell you you that one of
the singular Reasons I'm here is my
inability to judge myself for my
shortcomings when people hear what I say
they're like what I have to hold my no
no I hold myself to a great I want to be
the greatest entrepreneur of all time I
would argue that's a very high standard
that is different than when I make
inevitable missteps day in and week and
month and year out that I don't [__]
myself and say I suck [__] that [__]
stop beating yourself up all right here
first but that really gave me right here
some feels because it's hard I cannot
wait to see all of you
can't wait for all of you to get your
pins like the Olympics come and trade
them with me offer yours for mine
there's gonna be a lot of pin trading at
Becon this year I'm excited about that
[Music]
I'm really happy
to be here hi hi
yo yo yo
so I'm just extremely grateful for this
community so many of you made such good
friendships if I could encourage
anything try to go out of your way to
say hello to somebody in this room right
now keep expanding your circle how are
you good to see you I'm glad you're here
it's good to see you too thank you so
much for everything of course brother
it's been a tough year I know it has
that's why I wanted to get you before I
got out of here I appreciate it so much
I got a lot of love for you I love you
so much man I love you back send love
okay tomorrow for the goat meeting yeah
would you do the grace of FaceTiming my
mom it's a thousand percent
foreign
[Music]
57 News 19. vcon 2023 kicks off tonight
at Lucas Oil Stadium in Indianapolis the
business marketing and Innovation
conference drawing thousands from across
the country we're joined Now by Gary
vaynerchuk to talk about vcon 2023 so
first off why here pretty much because
it's an awesome City and I've been here
enough I've been to the NFL combine a
whole bunch of times I'm a die-hard Jets
fan so I've been here for some big Jets
coach games the reality is we're
bringing thousands of thousands and
thousands of very positive people to a
town and I want them to interact with
nice people we believe in civility
kindness empathy and nice and Indie
delivers on all of those is there a
shift in how you approached speakers and
panel topics this time around yeah I
think last year I was incredibly focused
on the education of new innovation so if
I was to do it this year like there
would have been 80 of the panels on AI
whereas this year I want to expand it
into kind of how I Envision it which is
the coolest business conference in the
world I you know I just know how
powerful you know actual friendship is
around like-minded interests or things
of that nature and just watching how all
of you are interacting with each other
is like a massive massive thing and a
lot of people talk about Community
obviously every community's got
different Ebbs and flows but I'm
incredibly proud and really genuinely
humbled by knowing the makeup of so many
people with this in this community and
so I'm just grateful I'm just really
excited
[Music]
second that's because he [__] me that
first one went through bro that's some
[__] that was [__] that first
one through it [__] went through I
don't understand what the [__] he did
how we doing
doing good I'm Warrior
my guy let's go
that's Fearless Ferry now has fired
all right selfie time
[Music]
you gave me uh gave me a lot of Courage
so I can quit my job I'm 62 last year I
was able to live my dream and I listened
to your podcast all the time and you
gave me courage to get out there I'm
proud of you bro it's amazing isn't it
bro happiness is worth fighting for it
makes me happy bro I just wanted to tell
you that right happy to hear it changed
my life and I just wanted you to know
that a 62 year old dude that there is
living a happier life
it's cool isn't it
um I just wanted to say thank you man
for the past like two years I was super
[__] depressed like in the drug use
comparing myself to friends they're
making like 100k a month I couldn't even
like hold a job yeah four months I
almost killed myself I almost ended it
but I said [__] that like now I'm
working on two business ideas I'm just
trying to turn everything around like
exercise like just get my [__] together
and I'm really like happy that I'm like
in a better mental space now I guess the
question for you is I have kind of like
a hockey project that I'm passionate
about which is an nft space and then I
have kind of this agency that I want to
start with software because I've been
working in software for a while how do
you choose where to focus your time
based on what I heard from you 80 20 80
20. let this be the fun and like like
but let this build a foundation for you
because you're coming from a vulnerable
place that you could build up I think
the bigger question is like what got you
to that place was pure Envy in
comparison you don't know what's going
on in my life don't envy anybody you
have no idea what's going on with
anybody in this place it may look good
it might be attractive they might have a
[__] Rolex you don't know what's in
their [__] Souls
today I would like want to be happy just
maybe more and more depressed I was just
going farther and farther down with
every accomplishment other people have
no bro nobody's accomplishments have
anything to do
yeah
thank you so much
I'm too good thank you happy to do it
I've been in this part of like
authenticity you are being one of The
Inspirations
me great we all have it inside of us we
just got to be brave enough to go for it
to identify it and I want to say thank
you because you're being a huge
inspiration only for me most of my
family but as well a lot of friends the
impact that you are creating the good
energy
done sets of everything is possible
optimism practical options
yeah of course of course we all know
what this is this is Way Beyond me this
is about a Common Thread that is
desperately needed in society which is
truth and positivity we need it you can
feel it I think we're off to a good
start
I want to thank this incredible group of
community members and I want to thank
all of you that supported this
incredible group of community members
really appreciate all of you I'm
cheering for all of you in a very
significant way I know you guys know
that and so let's clap it up for them
because that's a dessert
I can't wait for tonight I can't wait
for this weekend and I just can't
believe how great of a start we've had
keep treating each other the way you've
been so far I can't wait to see all of
you the rest of this trip let's [__]
go as right
yo dog face
let's go bro you made it
yeah man hell yeah the vibe is real man
proud of you bro I'm writing my new book
and the opening of the book is your
story hey that's what's up opening the
book I Wanna Give a huge shout out to
everybody who's been committed to
watching these matches especially this
crew right here
big shout out to the four players I see
you this is the trophy and this is what
the Winner's gonna get today which is at
least 100 bucks on eBay
this dress is [__] a mate this is
[__] amazing I love it
[Music]
it's my song
that's my [__] song
I got an idea
yo this is my [__] song
[Music]
[Applause]
you were lucky enough to be born during
this year
what's up Legend are you a champ how are
you great thanks for having us man
because
I said be Khan are you ready
because are you ready
I want the loudest possible warm welcome
for the [__] Legend bust a [__]
rhyme
you
[Music]
happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my first time
actually meeting my brother Gabby a
couple years now I'm looking at my bro
on that Instagram the thing that I love
about garyvee is how informative he is
truly a teacher no
the level of captivating energy that he
has is profound and I think that's the
reason why he's able to have all of us
in this room and I think that's the
reason why so many people have been able
to benefit
from watching them speak listening to
speak understanding what he speaks so
that if we know then why y'all to me on
my side was on my birthday he gonna pick
garyvee his [__] flowers right
now too
oh
we love you I love you too love you so
much brother I got I got one simple
thing to say all that comes down to one
simple thing let this be very [__]
clear love is unfucking defeated
she put your hands in the air drinks in
your cup
us to close it out a lot of love a lot
of real conversations
have a home trying to do it
but I just want to say thank you thank
you for supporting this thank you for
being a part of it yeah
foreign